after two months of rioting and
political chaos
there are still people out there who
claim this is all about the death
of george floyd believe it or not there
are some of the people who say that
may actually believe it we're giving
them the benefit of the doubt the
liberal mom who
lives next door to you for example she's
probably entirely sincere when she
lectures you about the scourge of police
brutality she means it
she has no idea blm is about anything
else
we're not judging and that's not
surprising most americans are nice
people they're literal and ingenuous
they tend to take claims at face value
because
they want to believe the best but in
this case they are wrong
none of what you are watching is about
civil rights
violence and race-baiting are the
enemies of civil rights
what you're watching instead is a power
grab it's being coordinated by the most
ruthless and cynical figures in american
politics
they don't want you to know what they're
doing they're not honorable enough to
state their intentions
they're not like you at all when normal
people want something they can be
aggressive
but the professional left never is it's
invariably
passive aggressive their first instinct
is to manipulate rather than persuade
they hide their real beliefs
they say precisely the opposite of what
they mean every time
they accuse you of the crimes they
themselves are committing
it makes your head spin arguing with
them is pointless by the way they're
nihilists
they don't believe in the existence of
truth or in the fixed meaning of words
they care only about power it's painful
to say this
it hurts to admit there are people in
our country who are like this
but there are and they have more power
than ever if you needed more evidence of
that barack obama showed up at
congressman john lewis's funeral today
obama claimed he was there to eulogize
his own friend but that's not true and
that's not what he did
instead obama gave a divisive and deeply
dishonest campaign speech
in church here's part of what he said by
ending some of the partisan
gerrymandering
so that all voters have the power to
choose their politicians not the other
way around
and if all this takes eliminating the
filibuster
another jim crow relic in order to
secure the god-given rights of every
american
then that's what we should do it's hard
to believe that clip is real
but it is down to the cloying fake
accent mr hawaii guy
but take three steps back imagine if
some greasy politician
showed up at your loved one's funeral
and started throwing around
stupid partisan talking points about
senate procedure
can you imagine that you would be
shocked if that happened you'd probably
walk out
desecrating a funeral with campaign
slogans
what kind of person would do that but
democrats in the audience didn't seem
offended they didn't blink they
cheered it all seemed normal to them and
why wouldn't it
political power is their religion it's
not out of place in a church it's what
they worship
people who will politicize a funeral
will do anything
and they're trying to democrats are
working systematically to dismantle the
core institutions
of american life beginning with the
family and with faith
they're subverting the core system in
our government the justice system
they're nullifying laws burning police
stations attacking courthouses
working to eliminate the legal equality
of american citizens the foundation of
it all
they've systematically repurposed
federal law enforcement agencies as
political weapons
they have imprisoned their political
opponents their leaders have called for
making all of these changes permanent
by packing the supreme court packing the
united states senate
packing the electorate itself by
importing tens of millions of new voters
why are they doing all of this they'll
tell you it's to make the country better
and more
just but the country isn't improving and
it's not fairer
they're doing this for one reason to
ensure they have complete control of the
united states
we're watching it happen right now
though almost no one ever admits it and
those who do
come close to getting shut down we can
tell you stories
so how should the rest of us respond to
what we're seeing and let's be clear
by the rest of us we're not talking
about conservatives or people who watch
the show we're talking about literally
everybody else moderates the politically
non-aligned traditional liberals who
still care about civil liberties there
are some of those sincere religious
people of
all faiths immigrants from abroad who
came to this country because of our bill
of rights
only to watch it evaporate once they got
here
in other words everyone who
fundamentally loves this country
which is still most americans what do
people like that
do in the face of this this revolution
well it's simple
defend the system that we have that's
our job
the american system is flawed no one
doubts that
but it works better than any other
system
in history and tearing it down will not
help in fact it will benefit only a few
the ones pushing for it
and it will crush millions so if you
care about the united states fight for
its institutions they have served us
well this country has survived almost
250 years through a civil war
let's keep going the president this
morning vented his frustrations on
twitter about potential voter fraud in
the upcoming election he wrote this
quote
with universal mail-in voting not
absentee voting which is good
2020 will be the most inaccurate and
fraudulent election in history it would
be a great embarrassment
to the united states we don't know if
that's
true we hope it's not it could be though
that's what the president wrote and then
he ended this way quote
delay the election until people can
properly securely and safely vote
end quote delay the election and that
was the headline
across cable news today and we should be
clear that will not happen the election
will
almost certainly take place in november
but at this point it's probably unwise
to suggest
changing the election voter fraud or not
too much is in flux already that's not
accidental it's by design
a bewildered population dealing with
change from
every possible direction cannot fight
back
that's why they're doing it so our job
is to defend what we already have
as a nation and to promote the
continuation of it
keeping things the same has never been
more important
than it is right now